[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce numéro spécial de paf
nous allons revenir sur le deuxième tour
des élections départementales et
régionales ayant tiré peut-être les
conclusions qui sont imposés pour en
parler marie le bec bonjour vous êtes
député elles mêmes des yvelines patricia
miou bonjour vous êtes secrétaire
départemental d'europe écologie les
verts vous étiez candidate dans le
canton de bouilly candidate malheureuse
au programme avec un joli score quand
même pour les voir on en reparlera parce
que il ya peut-être quelque chose qui se
passe à gauche entre les verts et les
autres forces
on en reparlera cyril notre bonjour vous
êtes monde url vous êtes l'ancien maire
de mantes la ville de l'éthique
candidats à monte là jeudi contre eux
pierre bédier pour le rm et vous avez
été battu ces mêmes masses peut-être
assez sévèrement mais on reviendra
peut-être sur le commentaire de de
chacune de ces élections avec nous aussi
boris venons bonjour bonjour vous êtes
membre du ps vous étiez vous candidate
dans le canton des mureaux
et vous n'avez pas gagné cette élection
avec nous si pierre dejean bonjour vous
êtes bonjour présenté ici est la france
a soumises oui et puis jean baptiste à
monique vous êtes maire de villepreux et
vous êtes le président du modem des
yvelines et philippe benassaya qu'ils
aient débuté l ère des yvelines et
conseiller départemental de saint cyr
l'école puisqu'il a été réélu va nous
rejoindre dans quelques instants là on
va aborder trois 3 domaines des
départementales des régionales en île de
france et puis peut-être des conclusions
sur le plan national est ce qu'on peut
te tire des conclusions de ce de ce
scrutin un mot quand même même si on y
reviendra dans la troisième partie sur
l'abstention malgré les prises de
paroles parfois même les engueulades un
peu des électeurs comme et comme l'a
fait marine le pen
il n'y a pas on regroupe plus de
mobilisation au deuxième tour qu'au
premier
est-ce qu'on entre dans une ère nouvelle
qui est ce qui est de la démocratie
abstentionnistes mari de bec
je crois qu'il ya en tout cas si c'était
le cas il faut absolument lutter contre
ça le vote cet endroit c'est un droit
qu'il faut exercer
absolument parce que c'est aussi
l'expression de l'orientation politique
que vous souhaitez donner à votre
territoire
moi je crois que trop souvent j'ai
entendu pendant cette campagne des
concitoyens me dire que ne savaient pas
à quoi allait servir la région que ça
n'allait rien changer dans leur
quotidien or on a fait sous le
quinquennat précédent de ces régions des
territoires dotés de compétences très
importantes de budget important aussi et
donc c'est fondamental et puis pour les
départements c'est le volet social qui
est important c'est le social de
proximité donc je crois qu'il faut
absolument rappeler quel est l'enjeu
mais aussi peut-être rappeler à certains
présidents de région sortants que nous
ne sommes pas dans une élection
nationale que parler de sécurité ce
n'est pas la compétence de ceux de ces
deux collectivités dirais qu'on a peu
parlé des problèmes de compétences des
régions et des départements réalité d'un
tel rôle et les âmes nationaliser
beaucoup ces élections on est
nationalisée
déplore et donc effectivement je pense
que d'une il faut redonner du sens à à
quoi servent ces deux collectivités
peut-être décorrélée les scrutins parce
que ça a été un élément de complexité
très important pour nos concitoyens
et puis ensuite je crois collectivement
quelles que soient les forces politiques
mobilisés pour lutter contre
l'abstention est rappelé que
effectivement voter c'est fondamental
c'est à millau ce oui c'est comme s'ils
se confirment un quand même bonne parce
que on est les chiffres comme ça au 10
65 % d'abstention ça veut dire qu'il ya
quand même 30 millions de français qui
ne se sont pas déplacés c'est quand même
énorme
c'est énorme mais si l'abstention est à
ce niveau-là faut se poser la question
pourquoi les gens ne vont plus voter
plutôt que de se dire les scrutins est
ensemble ça allait pas moi je pense que
il ya plusieurs raisons
il ya le fait que les gens ne
comprennent pas ce que c'est qu'une les
compétences des régions et les
départements et c'est quand même de la
responsabilité des élus en place d'avoir
faussé le débat en portant sur des
sujets qui n'étaient pas d'actualité
et puis l'autre raison c'est aussi un
mode de scrutin déjà avec deux scrutins
différents pour des compétences
différentes avec des modalités de
scrutin différent fallait vraiment trop
fallait comprendre ici on regarde les
yankees n'ont pas compris les tableaux
les tableaux qui vivent du du du
gouvernement sur les compétences des uns
et des autres et c'est extrêmement
compliqué c'est compliqué mais c'est
surtout que la représentativité des
des citoyens elle est bafouée parce que
même des sites dans le département des
yvelines qui est très largement à droite
depuis très longtemps
la gauche n'a aucune représentation la
droite en a fait son fleuron en disant
voter pour des candidats qui seront
minoritaires ne sert à rien ça veut dire
la démocratie ne sert à rien alors que
moi je pense que la démocratie est
fondamental et que donc le mode de
scrutin qui peut permettre à tout le
monde d'exister sur le plan politique
dans les assemblées c'est la
proportionnelle et tant qu'il y aura les
modes de scrutin au niveau c'est le mode
ça sera ça sera une des questions
peut-être alors on abordera tout ça dans
la troisième partie c'est le doute sur
vous et vous étiez présent lundi dernier
et je l'essayé ne pas trop me répéter
mais effectivement il ya on est tous on
voudrait tous
il n'y a pas eu de sursaut démocratique
au second tour mais j'aimerais quand
même ajouter plus que je n'ai fait la
semaine dernière
je pense qu'il ya une volonté de
sabotage du gouvernement qui est
actuellement en place la république en
marche savait qu'elle allait elle allait
échouer à prendre des régions et elle a
sciemment organisé une abstention
massive
prenons simplement l'exemple de l'envoi
postal d'envois l'envoi postal des
professions de foi était un échec total
je pense que c'est la première fois en
france qu'il ya un ratage conséquence
est en tout cas on peut en plein on peut
s'interroger quelque chose comme ça
c'est quand même un peu surprenant
oui avant de donner du principe on
constate en tout cas cet échec il ya
d'autres facteurs comme harry lumley
répondra non mais je crois qu'on peut
toujours trouver des excuses et des
prétextes pour expliquer le fait que
l'organisation était mal et l'élection
était mal organisé par don et qui sait
les raisons de l'abstention
moi je crois qu'il faut aussi peut-être
se remettre en question quand on perd sa
municipalité quand on perd aux élections
cantonales c'est peut-être aussi que les
électeurs ne veulent plus de ces
orientations politiques
il faut c'est pas une remise en cause de
la personne mais il faut savoir aussi
s'interroger sur du coup quelles sont
les élections je crois qu'on s'est
engagé non pas en se disant qu'on allait
remporter des régions même si on veut
tout gagner parce que on était un parti
qui est un peu rentrer sur le marché de
l'offre électorale des sans voix là et
que nous notre objectif c'était non pas
c'était de se positionner comme des
challengers en présentant un programme
des idées et nous sommes aujourd'hui si
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans des
oppositions c'est nous avons aussi pour
faire valoir ses perspectives l'a donc
non je crois pas qu'il faille dire que
c'est la responsabilité du gouvernement
ou alors c'est une façon bien fébrile de
se débarrasser du problème on ne
regardant pas émise en passant de
l'autocritique un un mot rapidement
alors parce qu'on va passer quand même
llanelli ses résultats sur sur cette
abstention dit boris venons par exemple
je pense que ça nous appellent tous à
une très très très grande humilité ce
quand on voit les scores dans certaines
villes
je prends l'exemple chez moi aux mureaux
c'est un électeur sur cinq seulement
qu'ils se dépasser et dans plusieurs
quartiers populaires c'est un électeur
sur dix
donc effectivement indiqué qu'ils
avaient développé et il y en a eu au
niveau de l'organisation de ce scrutin
mais au-delà de ça ça nous interroge
tout de même beaucoup sur la suite des
des institutions républicaines avec de
tels scores
moi j'appelle chacun à l'humidité
j'appelle la majorité sortante qui a été
reconduite avoir le triomphe modeste
c'est effectivement avec des scores
comme tels que cela va des élus qui est
je le regrette vont être ben ali lui et
vont effectivement avoir une légitimité
qui pourrait être remise en question
pour demande à ce qu'il ya comme
dommages en termes de démocratie
après juste pour compléter ce qu'on dit
vos intervenants ce qu'on a tous ratés
sur cette élection et et et jacques
chirac lui et les politiques et les
médias les institutions c'est aussi
d'expliquer en quoi ces élections ne
pouvait changer la vie quotidienne de
nos concitoyens
c'est vrai que on a beaucoup parlé je le
dis un très honnêtement on en a eu une
impression sur cette élection dans les
évident que le principal enjeu c est ce
que la droite va reconduire son grand
chelem ou pas est ce qu on a parlé
beaucoup des compétences du département
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme ça des du coup
de balai des enjeux de fond
malheureusement et pourtant il y en a et
beaucoup notamment dans ce département
qu'il ya un des plus riches de france
enfin le moins des 2 aux solidarités
pierre déjean peut-être c'est vrai que l
efi demande un ça va mais 6e république
alors on va on en parlera peut-être
dans la troisième partie de l'émission
mais sur sur justement cette abstention
très forte
y'a pas quand même une responsabilité
aussi des candidats je crois déjà qu' il
faut peut-être arrêter de par c10 et
j'entendais tout à leur dire qu' il ne
fallait pas nationaliser ces élections
en fait c'est un argument tout à fait
fallacieux
parce que j'imagine mal un des lecteurs
ou lectrices de gauche un scrutin est
voté à droite un autre spectacle surtout
surtout dans le cas où ils se déroulent
le même jour et que en fait c'est la
ligne politique générale qui compte et
après on l'appliqué au niveau national
au niveau régional au niveau
départemental en fonction des
différences compétences qui sont
attribués à ces organismes
c'est tout même sur le l'abstention je
crois que il faut pas insulter les
lecteurs l'abstention est un signe
politique
alors parfois difficile aide à décrypter
parce que justement l'abstention ne
donne pas de deux lignes mais on peut
dire que c'est un mouvement de grève
civique
c'est une opposition politique parce que
effectivement donné je disais rien et
ont été présentés ne sont ne donne pas
satisfaction
et en cela effectivement nous les filles
on propose la vème république parce
qu'il faut revoir tout le système scène
qu'en france parce que la 6ème
république pardon parce que
effectivement quelle que soit
l'organisation la démocratie bafouée où
la démocratie commence par une base très
simple un homme une voix
et tant que l'on n'a pas respecté cela
on a quand même des problèmes avec la
démocratie
donc ce changement de régime électoral
jean baptiste à munich
c'est vrai que ce que dit ce que dit
pierre dejean ya deux analyses aux faux
sur l'abstention il ya ceux qui disent
c'est une crise de la démocratie etc
très inquiétant et ce type disent au
fond c'est un appel au secours de gens
qui se disent qu'ils se reconnaissent
peut-être pas dans l'offre politique
quelle est votre analyse la vérité doit
être quelque part entre entre ces deux
propositions patrice moi ce que je pense
c'est que évidemment personne peut se
satisfaire de ce taux de participation
l'avait déjà dit la semaine dernière on
doit tous interroger collectivement
parce qu'on a forcément mon tant que
responsable de formation politique en
tant que militant de formation politique
aussi une autre part de responsabilité
en revanche moi je modérerait peut-être
un petit peu les choses parce que je
rappelle qu'avant ces deux scrutins
notamment sur les élections européennes
alors que nous attendons nous à lancer
une participation en baisse par rapport
aux précédentes européennes
on avait eu un regain de participation
donc moi je peux pas m'empêcher que le
scrutin de cette année des
départementales et des régionales à
conjuguer autour de autour de lui
plusieurs facteurs qui ont fait aussi
que 7,7
cette abstention est aussi élevé et on
sort à peine de la crise sanitaire
il ya évidemment des personnels qui a
plané qu'elles ont vécues ont envie de
penser à tout sauf de la politique
moi j'ai vu beaucoup de personnes partir
hors week-end je rappelle que le
couvre-feu a été levé aussi le week-end
précédent des gens qui sont partis
retrouver leurs proches qui n'ont pas pu
voir pendant un an
tout ça on peut pas juste le balayer
d'un revers de main après dire ça ça
veut pas dire botté en touche et ne pas
s'interroger sur des raisons plus plus
profondes de cette crise là moi ce que
je vois aussi c'est que le vote
protestataire qui a tendance à se porter
sur le rassemblement national mais pas
uniquement finalement aujourd'hui était
plutôt un vote en on vote à icc
il s'est traduit sur sur un fort taux
d'abstention il faudra voir moi je
j'attends réellement de voir comment ça
va se passer pour l'élection
présidentielle et les prochains scrutins
je pense qu'il ya un petit peu tôt pour
tirer des enseignements
ensuite un dernier mot là dessus en
parler de légitimité des élus ou des
deux candidats qui seraient mal élu en
raison du faible taux de participation
je crois que
quelque part aussi même s'il ya des
raisons à cela les absents ont toujours
tort et on peut pas vivre avec
avec avec ce propos là on peut pas dire
que les émissions sont mal et istres et
légitime je rappelle qu'aux états unis
on dit pas du président des états unis
quel qu'il soit qu'il est mal élu alors
que ou n'importe quel candidat n'importe
quelle élection américaine on voit qu
aux etats unis
historiquement il y a toujours à très
très faible taux de participation dans
ce pays alors c'est pas le modèle que je
fais pour la france mais il faut aussi
pouvoir relativiser les choses et
surtout voir comment ça se confirme dans
les sur les prochains scrutins
philippe benassaya bonjour député ldd
yvelines et conseiller départemental de
bois d'arcy vous avez été réélu un mot
rapide en ont parlé évidemment de
l'abstention il n'y a pas eu de
mobilisation entre les deux tours comme
le souhaitait un certain nombre dans
lequel les appels qui ont été lancés
c'est vrai que voilà on en est dit entre
crise démocratique appelle au secours
peut-être complexité de ces élections là
peut-être complexité aussi des modes de
vote parce que pour peut-être qu'on
pourrait aussi moderniser la façon de
d'aller voter peut-être que ça ça ne
résoudrait pas le problème en face à peu
près 6 litres et quand même les choses
maintenant que j'avais tout dit un peu
tout ça c'est à dire y avoir une
complexité du vote y avait d'un côté à
un scrutin de liste de l'autre en
scrutin binominal il y avait aussi des
hésitations sur les dates du vote des
reports part au port au port c'est un
peu ça un peu mis un peu le bazar dans
la tête des français puis il ya aussi la
complexité de l'enjeu je pense que les
français ne voient pas que les
départementales comme les régionales
c'est la vie quotidienne quoi c'est les
collèges ils ont tenté c'est très
important
les jambes elles nous disent les gens
qui nous disent bon moi j'irais pas
voter on les retrouve
à nos permanences dans la semaine pour
nous demander des renseignements sur les
collèges et lycées et donc c'est un peu
c'est un peu un peu schizophrénique
c'est à dire qu'ils vont pas voter mais
estime quand même que c'est important
est ce que parce qu'on parlait un petit
peu à ce qu' il n'y a pas eu peut-être
une erreur enfin une erreur peut-être
volontaires d'ailleurs de nationaliser
un peu le débat on a beaucoup parlé
marie levêque le disait de sécurité de
de terrorisme même parfois pour les
régionales peut-être pour les régionales
peut-être on entend un peu partout que
la régionale est un tour de chauffe
ouais c'est d'ailleurs dans ce pays je
veux parenthèse dans ce pays on est
totalement obsédé par la présidentielle
totalement que ces décès c'est quelque
chose qui est incroyable on ne parle que
de ça le présent et est exact et comtois
deux jours après on parle déjà dans cinq
ans qui va y avoir c'est une obsession
mais partagée par tout le monde veut pas
que les politiques des médias etc
moi j'ai fait le tour des plateaux télé
depuis hier on ne parle que des
présidentielles c'est affolant
personne n'a parlé des départementales
ou très très peu et on a parlé des
régionales mais juste pour dire que qui
va être le candidat de la droite
tellement hors président ses distances
droit maintenant
non mais c'est délirant c'est vraiment
de l'euro il ya peut-être aussi une
autre question qui est moi je me pose
cette question c'est est ce que il faut
peut-être pas modernisé aussi notre
notre façon de voter est ce que faut-il
toujours sacraliser le dimanche par
exemple comme jour de vote dans certains
pays' règle dans un vol dans la semaine
ce nom en angleterre dans la semaine est
ce qu'il n'ya pas une modernisation
c'est vrai qu'en france on sacralise un
peu on sanctuary sme l'élection
l'isoloir l'urne la mairie à l'école ce
qui est un magnifique magnifique parce
que c'est ces processeurs et placards et
une républicaine qui est très très très
intéressante mais escapade une façon de
moderniser sur votre je pense qu'il ya
une vraie question à se poser c'est vrai
que le comte françois bayrou l'a proposé
ça a été un petit con rejetée très vite
on en reparlera peut-être dans la
dernière partie des mesures doivent
maintenant cause
on va regarder un peu d'abord et la
première premiers résultats se succèdent
sur les départementales
[Musique]
alors ben je continue à le goût philippe
benassaya puisque l'eau des enjeux
c'était de savoir si la droite le centre
va l'alliance qui était derrière bédié
au fond ferait ou pas le grand chelem il
est fait il est fait mais même sur lie
pas fait ce n'était pas ce n'était pas
dramatique parce que la droite et ultra
majoritaire dans le département
elle est majorité derrière dans le pays
aujourd'hui au niveau territorial
puisqu'à chaque fois on gagne les
élections puis les municipales l'oubli
et puis le deuxième point c'est que la
stratégie de pierre bédier payante elle
a été payante c'est à dire à centre un
centre est et une droite ouverte mais
puisque nous nos candidats n'étaient pas
forcément heller et s'était privé d'un
modem avec un jeu voir mon remplaçant
sur le comptant de 2000 points saint cyr
et bois d'arcy qu'hier
si jean mathis à munich donc la
stratégie était plutôt payante c'est à
dire une stratégie ouverte une stratégie
pas forcément fermé sur sur des
étiquettes politiques donc la stratégie
a été payante le grand chelem a été
renouvelée ce qui est incroyable dans
nos pays je sais pas si à notre
département qui a fait le gros dos je ne
crois pas j'ai pas vu que j'ai pas vu
mais mais c'est vraiment une belle de
nouvelles stratégies une belle
récompense et puis et puis les résultats
aussi son très haut je pense que vous
avez dû vous avez parlé des résultats
des pourcentages
même si l'abstention est très très fort
bien sûr d'abord pas regarder on peut
regarder par les résultats en trois
jours très intenses ils voulaient
avec avec une victoire qui est donc le
canton de bois d'arcy de ça pour tous de
saint cyr avance sur l'école vos
services comme l'eau la boue alors si
oui c'est donc c'est une victoire très
nette très net avec une abstention forte
parmi mes avec sur les suffrages
exprimés une victoire très très nettes
mais qui est qui est un peu commune à
tous les autres cantons puisque les
autres cantons de l'est 21 quand on
tourne autour de ces de ces résultats là
donc c'est vraiment quand même une très
très très belle victoire ring et la
récompense d'une stratégie qui avait été
un petit peu bousculé au début un peu
contesté par certains mais qui en fait
est payante si elle note suppose que
vous partagez pas là mon la naissance de
oui je trouve ça plutôt un peu écoeurant
de renouveler ce grand chelem le mode de
scrutin est évoquée par madame tout à
l'heure effectivement le département des
yvelines est historiquement de droite de
centre droit qu'il conserve une majorité
dans ce département ça ne choquera
personne mais qu' aucune
aucun représentant de l'opposition que
ce soit à gauche au rassemblement
national dans un département qui compte
plus d'un million d'habitants
oui c'est pas rassurant pour la
démocratie
s'il y a pas d'opposition et a pas de
démocratie enfin on peut regarder les
résultats de menteur le canton dans
lequel vous étiez qu'on est là alors oui
quand-même victoire très nette de pierre
bédier vous aviez vous avez fait de
campagne assez assez dur en disant il
faut chasser y remédier des yvelines là
pour le coup c'est raté quoi ces ratés
oui bon là les rapports de force sont
assez semblables à ceux d'il ya 10 à 6
en réalité un
je note que la gauche pénalité à parra
trappe fait pas forcément beaucoup mieux
comme quand elle se retrouve face à un
binôme de droite ou de centre droit donc
oui c'est pas rassurant pour l'avenir
patricia bio justement voyez vous disiez
tout à l'heure c'est vrai c'est dit
c'est du félicite félicite du grand
chelem et dont on comprend pourquoi
mais vous avez nous vous disiez au fond
ce n'est peut-être pas très bon pour la
démocratie qui est un seul car très
mauvais pour la démocratie parce que
pendant si longtemps c'est le vote des
électeurs
oui mais après il ya le vote et puis la
méthode et quand globalement on dit sur
tout
surtout les tracts
voter pour un candidat qui sera
minoritaire c'est stérile c'est de dire
que ça ne sert à rien et qui vaut mieux
voter pour un candidat majoritaire je
trouve quand même que c'est un abandon
de démocratie de la part du parti les
républicains de dire que hors de moi pas
de salut et je trouve que c'est
scandaleux et dans mon canton
particulièrement la la fin de campagne a
été très difficile parce que on a eu
droit à un tract de purs mensonges en
dix points sur les écolos ils vont
refuser de donner des subventions
secours catholique mais où est-ce qu'on
voit ou est-ce qu'on va avec des
arguments pareils alors que jamais on a
refusé à rambouillet de financer la
restauration de l'église vous donner
deux des subventions à aucune
association caritative
enfin je trouve que c'est du mensonge
qui fait de l'effet aux gens parce que
moi j'ai reçu des messages me 2 me
disant est ce que c'est vrai tout ce
qu'ils disent
parce que évidemment si les écolos ils
étaient autant borné et obtus je
comprends qu'on vote pas pour eux mais
c'est pas du tout le cas et je trouve
que franchement c'est là on parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure mais c'est vrai
que aussi et surtout dans ce billet je
veux bien admettre que la droite est
contente mais sur le score de
rambouillet nous ont fait un pourcentage
vous pouvez les affidés ont les réfugiés
qui sont cristaux plutôt honorable
on fait 38 % à 6 5
moi je trouve que c'est plutôt un bon
score dans c'est vrai que les yvelines
sont un département très à droite je
n'en disconviens pas mais ça veut pas
dire il ya dix ans et l'autre de droite
et ils ne seront pas représentés pendant
six ans tout comme ils ne l'ont pas été
représentée pendant les six années
précédant et six années où on a eu
aucune information sur les débats ou
conseillers au conseil départemental
aucune information pour personne le bec
et les roms alors il était paraît il y
avait des candidats qui étaient
d'ailleurs qui sont maintenus au 2e tour
à versailles notamment
et puis il y avait d'autres candidats
qui étaient avec respire bédié c'était
compliqué pour vous ces couples écrit
pour nous les donnons c'était une
élection compliquée parce que en
fonction des cantons nous n'avions pas
partout choisi la même stratégie aux
municipales et vous que c'est bien que
ça reste une élection très numérique les
élections cantonales écueil à bédié
service au troisième tour voilà c'est un
peu le tour des municipales que
particulièrement le découpage des
cantons joue en faveur des mères des
plus grosses communes et voilà et c'est
une réalité qu'il faut savoir prendre en
compte il y avait dans des cantons dans
plusieurs cantons et dans plusieurs
villes
la reine qui avait soutenu le maire aux
élections municipales
il était de bon sens de le soutenir en
vue des cantonales sinon quelle logique
ça aurait créé pour notre électorat ce
qui n'était pas du tout la même chose
par exemple on reprend versailles 1 donc
le canton il y avait un binôme qui
s'étaient déjà présentés contre françois
de mazières et donc c'était aussi
logique qu'ils aillent qu'ils tentent
leur chance ils ont fait un score qui
est honorable également moi je
je prends acte de cette victoire de la
droite à la fois j'en suis satisfaite
pour le maire de la ville de houilles
question c'est un maire et les rues même
parce que il ça lui donne la possibilité
d'être élues d'avoir aussi une vision
sur sur le canton d'avoir aussi des
financements du département parce que
c'est un peu là le nerf de la guerre si
on se dit les choses
mais effectivement je rejoins quand même
les deux orateurs avant moi c'est que je
suis pas sûr que ce soit très sain et
c'est déjà le cas depuis six ans qu'il
n'y ait pas nos positions ne serait ce
que parce qu'en fait quand vous avez une
opposition vous êtes challenge est aussi
dans vos propres politiques en fin de
vie à l'assemblée et que ça vous oblige
à vous remettre en question ça vous
oblige à avoir une discussion avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes a
toujours essayé de convaincre est ce que
vous n'avez pas quand vous êtes un
département qui a uniquement la même
couleur politique
mais voilà c'est aussi le résultat d'un
découpage et d'un calcul doit être une
élection qui est très numérique donc il
faut aussi accepter que mécaniquement ça
joue peut-être en faveur des sortants ou
des mères fraîchement élu à peine il ya
à peine plus d'un an
on peut pas l'être deux cantons qui
était peut-être assez discuté c'était
celui des mureaux et celui de trappes
brise venant vous étiez candidat aux
mureaux qui a été un canton de gauche 1
avec françois garay il ya quelques
années me semble-t-il
là aussi bon la droite a confirmé sa
victoire de 2015 oui oui alors c'était
michel vignier voit dans les excuses et
moi qui était conseiller général
oui effectivement la droite a confirmé
son positionnement sur le canton il faut
le reconnaître et des reconnu les jets
style et david porte mais des
concurrents sans aucune difficulté après
voilà on sait très bien comment ça se
passe pour la gauche c'est à dire que
dans le contexte d'abstention kong
évoqué tout à l'heure c'est la gauche
qui at-il plus de désaffection des
électeurs par rapport aux urnes parce
que nous on a besoin du vote populaire
pour faire faire la différence
je note quand même et c'est une bonne
nouvelle
point de vue donc contrairement à il ya
six ans la gauche républicaine
progressiste et humaniste a réussi à se
hisser au deuxième tour de ces
départementale dans tout de même un
certain nombre de banques dont 16,6 je
ne hais ce qui est de mon point de vue
une bonne nouvelle pour le retour d'un
débat républicain au sens large du terme
dans notre département alors après je
rejoins ce qu'elles étaient en plateau
c'est vrai que malheureusement ça suffit
pas à faire en sorte qu'il y ait une
opposition qui reviennent aux camps
s'étaient pas et c'est dommage puisqu'il
ya des gammes des voix de toute une
partie de la population qui serait que
nous puissions porter moi je rejoins
complètement ce qu'a dit ma collègue
écologiste sur le manque de transparence
de la majorité d'arabes sortant ces
dernières années pour ceux qui ont fait
les exercices étaient très compliqué
d'avoir accès aux comptes rendus des
débats aux informations budgétaires
quand on n'est pas élu au crochet
départementale donc si la majorité
sortante pu faire un effort en matière
de transparence ce serait sans doute
profitable à l'ensemble
18 et puis surtout j'appelle moi la
majorité départementale est respectueuse
des consultations citoyennes
fréquentation organisée je connais
l'épisode je vous remercie de paille du
canton des bossales de nos cadres ont
parlé on a eu un épisode de consultation
démocratique sur un projet porté par le
conseil départemental déviation routière
qu'ils fassent a trait à terre et une
benne agricoles et des foires et des
habitants de trois villes et les maires
des trois villes ont indiqué leur
opposition à ce projet et pour autant le
conseil départemental adam indiqué qu'il
ferait ce projet voilà ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on ne pourra malheureusement
pas portée dans le conseil départemental
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'opposition
mais pour autant moi j'appelle le
conseil départemental à entendre aussi
ce que les habitants ont elles me dire
hors de l'hémicycle départemental avec
l'application citoyenne pas d'où tu veux
être organe vibrer ses rivaux les
réponses de divorce ou non non pas
spécialement j'entends bon je comprends
que lorsqu'on fait un grand chelem dans
un département ça puisse provoquer des
aigreurs ou des critiques qui est tout à
fait tout à fait normal et entendable
comme on dit d'un autre côté aussi il ya
eu des discours nationaux qui ont
peut-être un peu provoqué une peut-être
un effet repoussoir mis la gauche
surtout quand clément tin tin dit par
exemple ait menti nantes un allié avec
les écologistes à paris enfin de france
disant que ne subventionnerait plus les
écoles privées les associations ou les
os les églises etc
ça peut-être peut-être provoqué aussi
sorte de confusion même à gauche
peut-être même envahi rejeté un ailleurs
quand on est tout à fait sauter de ça à
part ça bon après ce sont des micros
problème j'entends mes mais c'est vrai
que bon la victoire est imposante elle
est importante
provoquer des questionnements jeu le
responsable mais l'engagement de
responsabilité d'abord ma scolarité ou
deux pour nos 600 pas d'opposition au
sein de il ya beaucoup de choses qui se
posent mais
voilà c'est les électeurs pourront
trancher c'est les électeurs ont décidé
personnes imposées selector quoi que ce
soit alors le condom le plus disputé
c'était celui de trappes puisqu'ali
rabais le maire de trappes était en tête
au premier tour
là encore c'est les bases nicolas
mainville et capio qui sont élus alors
après on peut on peut analyser c'est
vrai qu'il ya une plus grande
mobilisation dans des villes comme
elancourt 4 ap
il faudrait regarder en détail le vote
pierre dejean c'est une déception
jamais je crois que dans toutes les
analyses ya toujours des choses dont on
se satisfait de ton on est mécontent
mais je crois que finalement il faut
faire revenir aux principes de la
démocratie mois que la droite soit
majoritaire dans le département
évidemment c'est pas mal c'est pas mon
option politique donc c'est une source
de mécontentement on peut le dire mais
ça fait aussi partie de la démocratie
sauf que la démocratie n'est pas
respectée parce que du coup aucune autre
force que la droite va être représentée
au département et la démocratie bien
entendu c'est se base sur le fait
majoritaire mais aussi sur la place qui
est donnée à la ou aux minorités et là
il n'y aura pas donc c'est une apparence
de démocratie mais ce n'est pas une
démocratie du tout et quand j'entends
monsieur benasayag dire qu'il faut
moderniser le scrutin moi j'ai les plus
grandes craintes chez les plus grandes
craintes parce que à chaque fois qu'on
nous parle de de modernisation de
simplification la simplification s'amène
complexification et on a eu des lois map
damées et nôtres par exemple récemment
et la modernité vous savez les gens
tentent tout de suite venir le scrutin
par internet et qui encore une négation
de la démocratie parce que ça ne
garantit absolument pas la sécurité du
scrutin
et ni de secret rien du tout donc
bonjour ans fait déjà pas des paiements
bancaires par internet et on ne
viendrait pas à un scrutin
loyal non pas du tout parce que c'est
pas du tout de même nature
c'est pas du tout de même nature quand
vous payez par internet vous ne vous ne
retirez pas à aucun moment l'anonymat au
contraire puisque ce qu'il faut qu'ils
devaient payer alors que dans le scrutin
c'est vrai qu'il ya les loyers m'a pas
de coupure entre les lecteurs et le vote
exprimé à un moment donné on peut pas
faire de lien sinon 1e mutsch secret de
vote
alors on va passer aux élections
régionales d'abord défoncé oui pardon
vendront jean baptiste pendant que bercy
je voudrais juste réagir rapidement à ce
qui a été dit je crois qu'on peut pas on
peut pas comment dire accusé les
candidats de la majorité départementale
d'avoir provoqué la mort provoquée
comment dire une crise démocratique en
remportant les 21 cantons bout d'un
moment c'est aussi les votes des
électeurs il faut quand même il faut
quand même se le dire qu'on s'interroge
après sur la représentativité des
différents courants politiques qui se
présentent aux candidats qui se
présentent aux élections ça oui
évidemment on peut s'interroger et ça
posait la question du mode de scrutin
ça pose la question aussi c'est ce que
c'est ce que disait pierre déjean de 2,2
au delà même du mode de scrutin de deux
de l'opération de vote
excluant modernise comment nos derniers
mois je rappelle que modem avait fait
des propositions sur sur votre par
correspondance je crois qu'il ya pas mal
de choses hein qui existent aujourd'hui
qui sont sur la table et faudra vraiment
qu'on en débatte très sereinement après
juste un dernier mot
quand on a fait la campagne avec
philippe des départementales ce que
j'entends beaucoup parler de droit du
centre-gauche
on n'a pas fait de campagne sur les
étiquettes on a fait une campagne à la
fois sur le bilan des conseillers
départementaux sortant mais aussi sur
les projets et moi ce que je constate
c'est que cette victoire ce grand chelem
c'est surtout non pas une prime aux
sortants mais une prime à l'implantation
locale et en cela ce scrutin
départemental a été très intéressant
parce que je trouve je trouve qu'il a
été des nationalités
contrairement aux élections régionales
mais que par des électeurs qui provoque
ce grand chelem pour la majorité
départementale sortante
c'est aussi la volonté de continuer avec
des élus de terrain et de proximité qui
selon eux ont bien fait leur boulot et
qui portent des projets intéressants
pour territoire alors merci beaucoup
jean baptiste aveni qu'on va on va
passer maintenant justement ce quota
qu'on a un peu plus nationaliser celui
des régionales
on va commencer par les zidane en
ile-de-france évidemment alors victoire
nette de valérie pécresse en ile de
france
malgré l'union de la gauche si je peux
dire passer sa bio les trois listes
c'est un malgré ou peut-être à cause on
va voir mais je redis que l'abstention
fait que l'interprétation du scrutin et
quand même aléatoire sur la volonté des
habitants d'île de france de vouloir
lire pécresse là la région parce que
avec autant d'abstention rien et rien
n'est jamais sûr il ya les frais et la
campagne de désinformation de valérie
pécresse je persiste à dire que ça de
l'importance quand on voit des gros
bandeau jaune qui disent si vous voulez
voter pour julien bayou vous votez pour
les islamo gauchiste franchement je
voudrais qu'on m'explique ce que ça peut
vouloir dire déjà et je trouve que ces
deux là c'est c'est là
c'est de la désinformation c'est du
mensonge c'est une élection où quand
même où il ya de la proportionnelle donc
le poids de chaque de chaque partie et
quand même du moins en ce qui concerne
les partis qui ne sont pas majoritaires
proportionnelle après il ya une prime à
la liste par parvenus en tête ce qui
fausse la presle à la proportionnelle
mais sans doute qu'il ya des gens qui
n'ont pas voulu voter pour julien bayou
à cause de la présence de clémentine
autain et de sa liste mais sans doute
aussi qu'il ya des gens qui ont voté
julien bayou qui n'avaient pas voté
julien bailly au premier tour parce que
il ya des gens qui attendent l'union de
la gauche
je pense qu'on peut pas laisser voir une
intention de trois listes devraient
dynamique dont on arrête dynamique ou
positif mais on peut pas savoir si c'est
parce qu'il ya la présence de la france
à soumises ou si c'est parce qu'on n'a
pas fait alliance au premier tour on
saura jamais ça mais justement je
reviens ce que vous disiez parce que on
a beaucoup parlé du front républicain en
paca joli contre la présence de
rassemblement national
est ce qu'il n'ya pas eu une sorte de
front républicain d'île de france quand
vous voyez manuel valls et jean paul
huchon qui disent qu'ils sont des
sociaux-démocrates qui dit faux il faut
voter pécresse parce que justement il ya
un danger à gauche avec avec ôta
peut-être avec
bayou qui est peut-être des positions
plus extrémistes que d'autres d'autres
verts est ce que ça vous fait pas
réfléchir c'est intéressant
personne n'a parlé beaucoup de sang mais
interpelle c'est vous me dites jean paul
huchon a appelé à voter pécresse mais
vous me dites pas lionel jospin a appelé
à voter bayou il ya déjà une distorsion
parce que personnellement je comprends
la donne rien
la mecque la plupart des sociétés je
suppose robo t il y avait je n'en sais
rien n'aurait pu le voir mais ce que je
sais c'est que c'est que quand associé à
un ancien socialiste parce que j'ai
entendu sion ne sais pas si c'est la
région il n'est plus au parti socialiste
annonce qui va voter pécresse on en fait
la une des journaux et quand lionel
jospin ancien premier ministre annonce
qu'il va voter julien bayou pour tel et
tel réseau personne n'en parle
moi je trouve que c'est pas très
équitable comme façon de faire donc
après les électeurs se base pas sur le
fait que manuel valls qui est allée un
coup en espagne à pau en france qui
cherche un post cac pas bon voilà c'est
pour moi c'est c'est révélateur d'un
état d'esprit d'une certaine partie de
mes est ce qu est ce que vous dites pas
aux fouilles un front républicain pour
éliminer leur assemblée nationale il
pourrait y avoir un front républicain
peut-être pour éliminer la france est
soumise ce qu'on appellera le dd mais on
a parlé d'islam au gauchisme l'intérêt
d'une proportionnelle c'est justement de
se mettre d'accord sur des projets on
peut très bien et ça se vérifie au
parlement européen votée des projets qui
ne sont pas portés par notre propre
parti au parlement européen ça se fait
tous les désaccords
c'est même pas des accords négociés
cessé de dire ben ce projet là bas je le
trouve bien donc je vais le voter qui
que ce soit qui les portait et là avec
clémentine autain on a un certain nombre
de sujets sur lesquels on est totalement
d'accord un certain nombre de sujets sur
lesquels on est partiellement et un dos
tourné pas du tout à le faire mais ça
n'empêche pas que face à une à une
présidence de région pécresse qu'on a
déjà eu pendant un certain temps et on a
vu ce que ça donnait pour de notre point
de vue ça justifie de s'unir sur des
projets et jeu
je trouve que la la la médiatisation de
la présence de clémentine autain est
surfaite en plus les gens plus que
moyenne atteint et peut-être une fille
présentable si je veux dire entre
guillemets moi je suis mort à d'autres
trier dénommé présentable et pas
présentable chacun défend ses idées avec
des raisons d'exister de gens mais voilà
mais je trouve que à la dent dans la
future assemblée
les partis politiques qui ont fait cette
union ont une représentation
proportionnelle en sièges
je trouve que c'est que les milliers des
régions à lagos et est en passe de
pouvoir gagner et où semble-t-il ben
cette alliance n'a pas marché je pense
avec orphelins notamment oui mais voilà
ce que vous faisiez peut-être eu un
rejet de sa aussi enfin peut-être des
baies d'açaï et sur ce point
non mais j'ai bien compris je pense vos
questions la question sur le front
républicain anh est très claire jeudi en
général le front républicain c'est quoi
c'est ça ne casse de gauche pour essayer
d'imposer à la droite de ne l'indiquent
contre le contre le rassemblement
national et jamais lorsqu'il s'agit de
l'extrême gauche
premier point le deuxième point c'est
que on parle d'une honda gauche mais je
pas sur ça soit une union de la gauche
comme en ile de france on a une union de
la gauche et de l'extrême gauche avec 3
3 positions de gauche plutôt différente
pas sûr que les socialistes soient
vraiment sur la même ligne que les
écolos bayou et que l'extrême gauche qui
a pris soin ses membres ou alors on est
aveugle dans ce pays mais une extrême
gauche il a pris des positions
extrêmement violente à l'égard de la
république à l'égard plutôt plutôt
bienveillante à l'égard de l'islamisme
notamment dans des manifestations la
manifestation de la honte comme on l'a
appelé je passe je suis pas sûr mais
c'est pour ça qu'elle accepte cette
cette union hétéroclite a perdu c'est
parce que les additions et et répliques
ne font pas une élection c'est tout on
ne peut pas additionner arithmétiquement
3,3 courant qui sont différents il ya un
courant socialiste avait un courant
écologiste
il y avait un courant d'extrême gauche
pas sur ça y ressemble
ce sont des désunions de circonstance
pour essayer de gagner des élections et
placer des gens sur des listes mais les
français ne sont pas reconnus dans cette
dans cette union hétéroclite alors il
peut y avoir un front républicain contre
cela pourquoi pas après tout payé par un
front républicain contre l'extrême
gauche ici c'est passé d'ailleurs je
pense et puis mais ne soyons pas
aveugles
on connaît très très bien les positions
politiques de l'extrême gauche
on a parlé d'un d'hygiénisme de
communautarisme d'islamistes c'est vrai
voilà il faut le dire
toutes les positions de l'extrême gauche
sont sur ce domaine là à chaque fois que
l'extrême gauche prend la parole est ce
que les sociétés se reconnaissent
l'adorent je ne crois pas et est ce que
les écolos se reconnaissent là dans un
petit peu plus en effet que des
socialismes marie lebey que vous
regrettez pas finalement que valérie
pécresse n'est pas proposé une alliance
avec laurent saint martin qui était le
candidat des les roms enfin moi je crois
que c'était important que la république
en marche dans un maximum de régions et
notamment dans une région qui compte
quand même un électorat dynamique pour
le président de la république puisse se
présenter et défendre un projet moi je
crois que dans l'entre-deux tours nous
avons pu avoir des discussions dans
certaines régions sur l'éventualité d'un
rapprochement mais sur effectivement la
concordance des projets jean pas tout à
fait à philippe benassaya je suis
d'accord que numériquement c'est pas
parce que vous additionnez de liste que
de l'intégralité des voix se reportent
mais vous pouvez aussi considérer un
moment que vos projets ne sont pas très
loin et que malgré tout il faut pas être
non plus naïfs le but de chaque candidat
c'est de remporter l'élection et que
donc ça pouvait faire sens effectivement
d'avoir une alliance de la gauche même
si effectivement moi je suis pas sûr que
toutes les toutes les
tous les électeurs de gauche se retrouve
dans la liste qui était fort très
partante mais pardon mais c'est juste
qu'il faut arrêter dire ça c'est une
élection à la proportionnelle
il m'a dit c'est une élection très
prochainement vainqueur de l'exemple qui
est le plus flagrant je pense c'est que
nous avons le score le plus faible en
ile de france c'est indéniable ce qu'on
est à 10,10 je crois et que nous avons
quinze élus donc c'est une élection à la
proportionnelle est ce qu'on peut
arrêter de dire aux gens c'est pas une
élection à la proportionnelle c'est pas
vrai c'est une avec une prime
le premier majoritaire mais je crois que
c'est de tradition française de
considérer que c'est effectivement une
majorité stable pour permettre de
diriger quelque peu importe la
collectivité que ce soit de la
municipalité à la région mais voilà ça
c'est pas aberrant je trouve que dans le
fonctionnement
et oui moi je pense que c'était
intéressant pour la république comment
tu vas voir dans un certain nombre de
territoires des discussions qui sont
engagés dans l'entre-deux tours pour
voir si la cohérence des projets pouvait
s'allier donc je note que que ce soit
valérie pécresse ou dans d'autres
régions
la porte a été fermé et que donc c'était
le sens aussi de maintenant de prendre
date sur dires de jean lé fils et le
gauchisme
non non non actuellement pas ce terme de
gauchisme utiliser n'importe où
n'importe comment et ne signifie rien
pour cela il faudrait se référer au
livre de lénine le gauchisme maladie
infantile comme et passons là dessus je
vois en tout cas que monsieur benasayag
fait fait corps avec l'extrême droite
pendant dix ans au terme de dix la mort
gauchistes qui n'a aucune consistance
politique
hormis la détestation que l'on a de l'un
et de l'autre c'est à dire d'un côté de
l'islam dit ça c'est du dur racisme et
de le coter contre la gauche
c'est tout et c'est une expression qui
n'a pas d'autre signification que que
cela et quand il passe la manifestation
de la honte c'est encore un mensonge
absolu pour pour cela parce que c'était
quoi
c'était une manifestation pour
manifester la solidarité par rapport à
des gens qui avaient été victimes
je crois que c'est d'un attentat
quelconque même minime mena est donc
tout simplement contre eux contre le
contre le racisme
et ben si monsieur benasayag ne veut pas
manifester contre le racisme
lorsque les victimes sont musulmanes ça
s'appelle du reste être d'apporter des
étoiles jaunes par exemple la vie claire
canton quand il ya une manifestation on
se fie au mot d'ordre de cette
manifestation
après qu'ils aient quelques super lui
qui ont peut être déviée et et fait des
choses répréhensibles
on est prêt tout à fait les condamnés
mais ça ne compte ça ne joue ça
n'entraîne pas la globalité de tous les
gens qui étaient là et je vous signale
en tout hasard que si vous reprocher à l
efi d'être présent cette manifestation
vous devriez regarder l'ensemble des
organisations qui étaient à plantes pour
être le plus qu'un c'est net c'est est
interrogé pierre déjà je vous interdis
peut on peut faire barrage
un candidat ou pas c'est autre chose
mais ce n'est pas une ligne politique
donc ça veut rien dire si est le nôtre
oui sur c'est sur ces questions de 10 la
mobo schisme de communautarisme moi je
trouve quand même que la droite est très
mal placé pour me montrer du doigt la
france insoumise
on peut aussi donner un certain nombre
d'exemples d'islam au clientélisme
bruno beschizza par exemple maire
d'aulnay-sous-bois avait été émise en
cause il ya plusieurs années par jordan
bardella ce même maire donc peut-être de
liste départementale dans le 93 sur la
liste de madame pécresse a fait
plusieurs procès en diffamation contre
jordan bardella il les a tous gagnés
on peut aussi parler de pierre bédier au
val fourré comment croyez-vous qu'il
parvient à réaliser des scores de
dictateurs africains dans tous les
bureaux de vote du du val fourré voilà
il y à il ya aussi si on veut utiliser
l'expression l'islamo gauchisme faudra
peut-être la définir c'est vrai mais en
tout cas là la droite est très mal placé
pour ce sujet là j'aimerais d'ailleurs
ajouté que le nouveau maire de man que
la ville sammy d'énergie en huitième
position sur la liste de madame pécresse
a dans sa majorité à nantes la ville
une haie d'une conseil municipal qui
était tête de liste de l'udf l'union des
démocrates musulmans français
elle s'appelle madame aicha ya elle
porte le voile compris en conseil
municipal
donc je crois que la droite n'a vraiment
pas de leçon à donner sur la laïcité ou
sur ces questions de communautarisme ou
d'islam au clientélisme est libre et
dacia
non je suis pas de procès à dominer mme
déjean c'est pas ma culture politique je
ne cible pas les gens en fonction de
l'heure de leur choix politiques sur des
listes premièrement deuxièmement je dis
juste et je répondais à votre question
que le front républicain est toujours à
sens unique et jamais dans un option
c'est est ce que je disais et que
deuxièmement les additions ne font pas
les élections voilà que je pense
peut-être que c'est cette cette union
des gauches n'a pas n'a pas recueilli
l'adhésion dit francine r parce qu'elle
était peut-être contre nature dans cette
alliance
oui après vite ça me fait un peu rire
vous servir au tragi comique c'est à
dire que vous avez tous les uns les
autres et moi y compris à part était de
dire c'était un regret d'avoir
nationalisé le débat des régionales
et c'est exactement ce qu'on est en
train de faire ce matin bon voilà au
bout d'un moment faut faut aussi être
cohérent avec les propos qu'il a pu
tenir auparavant je rappelle quand même
que évident on n'est pas d'accord
surtout entre les écologistes les
socialistes dire qu'enfin soumises
sinon on serait quand même parti or
j'aime pas c'est bien qu'il ya des
points de divergences sur certains
points sur certains sujets
par messieurs vous avez traité ce matin
il y en a un certain nombre à la après
sur les régionales on s'est mis d'accord
et ça a été très long mais chacun
d'entre vous c'est sur un programme
commun mais c'est lent c'est pas juste
acoquiné les uns avec les autres parce
qu'il y avait un intérêt électoral il ya
eu des discussions de fond sur les
projets ce qu'il ya des années est
reportée en commun c'est sur cette base
là accueillait trois familles politiques
qui sont différents se sont réunis et
tout alors je tiens juste en profiter
pour rappeler quand même parce que ça a
été cité dans le débat que messieurs lui
change des vans se sont éloignés dérive
sociale démocrate c'est un certain poids
donc voilà je retire aujourd'hui le
joueur patrice à millau sur ce qu'ils
disent est ce qu on a fait quand même
beaucoup sur eux alors que venait
objectivement il ne représente
malheureusement plus grand chose qu'eux
mêmes et qu'il aurait été de bonne tenue
effectivement de valoriser vous aussi
les gens qui s'inscrivent on pourrait
pas que jean que sa rencontre
voilà ce que j'avais à dire sur sur le
sujet alors on va passer au dernier ta
veste et lire les leçons est ce qu'on
peut en tirer des leçons de ces scrutins
notamment d'aidés régionales
au plan national il ya les deux favoris
pour la présidentielle emmanuel macron
et marine le pen est une autre aussi je
vous interrogez tu sais sur les deux
parties qui ont perdu ces élections
est-ce que ça remet en cause c'est vrai
que les français ne souhaitent pas non
plus d'avoir ce ce duel en 2022
est-ce que ça remet en cause les choses
d des deux principaux favoris des choses
peut-être les français ne le souhaitent
pas avoir ce duel c'est pas exactement
ce qu'ils faisaient
laissons d'agir de
en vue de la présidentielle mais si on
met ça de côté si vous me permettez
cette cette petite remarque par rapport
à ce qu'on trouve intéressant parce que
souvent quand les français ne souhaitent
pas un duel et n'a pas lieu mais oui
j'avais la suite de mon propos je crois
pas que d'une l'abstention permettent de
nationaliser afin d'avoir une analyse
sur l'impact national de ces élections
et je crois ensuite que effectivement on
a vu peut-être c'est intéressant je
trouve politiquement se dessiner en
france 2 2 2
des forces politiques très différentes
des forces politiques au niveau
territorial que sont peut-être le parti
socialiste et enfin on va dire la gauche
+1 jeumont et les républicains qui met
effectivement reporter partis
traditionnels ici les partis
traditionnels et que nous avons toujours
malgré tout en tête dont ce qui concerne
la lecture des élections nationales
plutôt le rassemblement national et
laïque en marche qui domine la vie
politique nationale donc je pense que
c'est aussi intéressant peut-être par
rapport à notre question de l'abstention
qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure de
considérer qu'il y a désormais une voix
territoriale est une voie nationale et
qu'il est très difficile de croiser les
deux et que donc je ne pense pas ni au
vu de l'abstention ni au vu de dieu de
la façon dont est redessinée pour lui le
paysage politique français
qu'il faille tirer des enseignements
pour la future campagne présidentielle
c'est une haute c'est quand même alors
faible score du jour de bardella et puis
surtout la défaite de marianne et en
paca d1 la défaite de mariani est ce que
ça remet pas en cause au fond le
recentrage du rn 10 que c'était c'est un
ans et vise istres de nicolas sarkozy
mariani donc le côté plus présentable
2rm finalement est ce que là on a
beaucoup dit ça après après le premier
tour déjà et même après le second tour
un essai d'ailleurs une vieille phrase
un le front national un front national
trop gentil ça n'intéresse personne
c'est une phrase qui a été prononcé et
déjà plusieurs années je suis pas sûr
que ce soit vrai on verra on verra dans
l'air on verra les élections donc dans
quelques mois mais en l'occurrence mais
il ya quand même cette incapacité à
gagner une élection pas rassemblé un peu
plus qu'au premier tour c'est vrai mais
en même temps ce scrutin a été marqué
par une abstention très forte dont nous
avons été particulièrement victimes donc
effectivement il est très difficile à
mon sens d'en tirer des enseignements
non je pense que les les sortants ont
été assez facilement et brillamment
réélu c'est une réalité on en prend acte
après je pense que ce soit les l'air ou
le parti socialiste ça reste une sorte
de syndicat d'élus locaux ils n'ont ils
n'ont pas vrai de vrai leader jusqu'à
présent en tout cas pour porter leur
voix à l'élection présidentielle et
effectivement les sondages même s'il
faut se méfier
dommage on l'a vu pour les élections de
dimanche dernier emmanuel macron marine
le pen vraisemblement son ensemble
toujours toujours bien placé et en
l'occurrence même s'il ya de nouvelles
personnalités enfin nouvel antre du mec
qui émerge comme xavier bertand ou
d'autres de toute façon ce ne sont pas
des personnalités qui prendront des voix
à marine le pen au premier tour
à mon sens donc il va falloir maintenant
il va falloir évidemment créer une
dynamique puisque l'absence de victoire
nous prive de cette dynamique pour
lancer la présidentielle c'est à marine
le pen de bien travailler sur ça sur sa
campagne sur la manière dont elle va
aller à la rencontre des français dans
quelques mois felipe est d'essayer alors
c'est vrai qu'on entend du xavier
bertrand valérie pécresse et laurent
wauquiez d'ailleurs prendre prendra acte
de leurs victoires et se place et
peut-être pour le combat de la
présidentielle est-ce que c'est pas
quand même des victoires trompe l'oeil
c'est vrai qu'il ya des 30 millions de
français qui sont pas allés voter y est
relativement peu de donc peu peu de voix
c'est une prime au sortant est ce que ça
leur donne la légitimité qu'il
je pense qu'ils la question encore une
fois l'obsession présidentielle nous
aveugle les équilibres régionaux n'ont
pas bougé en fait non c'est ça la gauche
a gardé ses gardes et sa région la
droite incarné ces régions il est même
en art com - comment elles mêmes et on
recommence on a jugé probablement les
présidents de gauche comme de droite
d'ailleurs sur leur bilan carole delga
c'est la seule saison en indy date qui
unit ça irait les intervalles et sur les
autres candidats ne ment pas ça se voit
et ça devrait nous interpeller sur
l'évolution des politiques c'est à dire
que plus on est sur le terrain plus on
est on a un bilan territoriale important
mieux on est élu je pense que la
politique d'en haut c'est à dire hors
sol un peu sans sans bilan local sans
bilan territoriales et des avoués
probablement dans ce pays et la prime va
à ceux qui ont un bilan et à ceux qui
ont un ancrage territorial important
c'est qu'à gauche comme c'est le cas à
droite puisque les équilibres n'ont pas
n'ont pas bougé à part après ça s'il
faut encore parler des présidentielles
bien évidemment les duels annoncés
n'arrive jamais où ça c'est sûr depuis
les céni depuis des décennies les pays
tiers les cobras de clip haut en 69
les des bilans non les duos comme ça les
duels annoncés ne n'arrive jamais
concentrons-nous un petit peu sur sur le
résultat de ces régionales et
départementales qui à la fois bombe sur
l'abstention de la prime au sortant
3 la victoire de la droite quand même
chez désolé ici de vous lire et 4
forcément une prime probablement aux
élus de terrain et ça c'est important
jean baptiste à monique le justement là
évidemment emmanuel macron
il est quand même très seul ça veut dire
quoi très seul non là où je rejoins je
pense que il faut se rappeler comment
les manomètres mais macro avec les lieux
en 2017 il créer quelque chose de
nouveau avec un parti aussi qui n'est
pas le mien mais qui est le parti
majoritaire de la majorité
présidentielle la république aux marches
et marie-mai mec l'a dit et c'est très
juste qui a besoin de temps aussi pour
s'implanter
c'est une nouvelle offre politique il va
lui falloir du temps pour trouver aussi
un ancrage une assise territoriale mais
je crois que c'est ce qui a aussi
cruellement manqué à ce quinquennat n'a
plus que des relais c'est l'implantation
locale c'est d'avoir au côté des
ministres aux côtés des parlementaires
aux côtés des mesnel macron des mères
viennent résidence des présidents de
conseils départementaux en tout cas des
élus d'expérience qui ont une bonne
connaissance des sujets locaux et du
terrain et je crois que en tout cas si
les candidats car je le rappelle que
préside la république n'a pas encore
annoncé sa candidature à sa réélection
même si ça semble être un secret de
polichinelle encore que 1 sait jamais il
peut y avoir des surprises
je crois que s'il est candidat il faudra
qu'il aborde cette élection
présidentielle d'une façon un peu
différente que qu'en 2017 après
honnêtement patrice bien malin
aujourd'hui un an
l'un - dan opéli r&d ce qui valait placé
pour dire ce qui va se passer
en tout cas c'est vrai qu'on disait que
malheureusement les régionales avaient
été nationalisées et que l'on nous a
expliqué en tout cas certains candidats
nous ont expliqué qu'il ne fallait pas
les nationaliser vous voyez très bien
les réactions des différents présidents
de région nouveau président de région
réalisme crack soient de gauche ou
qu'ils soient de droite il se projette
déjà tous sur l'élection présidentielle
donc pour le savez je veux dire ça ça
fait aussi partie du jeu politique
maintenant on va voir qui sont ceux qui
vont émerger dans les prochaines
semaines et dans les prochains mois on
va attendre de voir quelle est l'offre
politique aussi à gauche à droite aux
extrêmes et sur l'espace central et
c'est à ce moment là qu'on pourra je
pense commencer à voir quel duel
pourrait pourrait émerger mais c'est
bien trop tôt moi je connais pas
rassemblement national jean-pierre pas
marine le pen s'il faut rester vigilant
je pense que l'électorat frontiste
aujourd'hui ne s'est pas mobilisée sur
ces élections locales notamment au
second tour il a privilégié l'abstention
mais je crois qu'il pourra aussi se
mobiliser à nouveau sur sur la
présidentielle donc il ya une vigilance
à avoir il faut continuer à travailler
le quinquennat et pas terminée non plus
il ya un corps éventuellement quelques
réformes à faire passer il ya un accord
il ya encore des choses à faire avant la
fin de ce mandat là donc je crois qu'il
faut utiliser lequel temps qui reste du
quinquennat position pour continuer à
avancer avant la prochaine
présidentielle
merci beaucoup merci à tous j'ai juste
une question mais par oui ou par non pas
trio est ce que justement l'union de dd
gauche et les nécessaires pour les
présidentielles ben moi je trouve que
d'entendre dire ça va être macron le pen
s'est pas favorisé la baisse de
l'abstention c'est s'est dit roy tout
l'électorat de gauche c'est même pas la
peine que vous y alliez puisque ça sera
la droite contre l'extrême droite je
trouve que c'est dramatique - des
discours comme ça je pense que il faut
faire des projets il faut faire défaut
discuter entre avec des partenaires et
on verra bien on verra bien on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler de tout ça
merci merci à tous les sept là va
participer à cette émission est très
vite on va reparler évidemment des
présidentielles dès l'année prochaine
fois dès la rentrée prochaine merci à
tous
[Musique]